[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to februari it's a month of love
so we've got plenty of historical
violence retro gameplay and trippy
puzzles to solve alright maybe it's not
so romantic after all but in any case
let's talk about the biggest games
launching soon and don't forget to
subscribe to catch all the hottest
releases every week neyo started
development in 2004 but now we're
finally getting our hands on the brutal
samurai combat game if you like dark
souls you'll feel right at home neo puts
you in control of real life Western
samurai William Adams who's tasked with
hunting down yokai across a dark
fictionalized version of San Goku era
Japan you can expect to tangle with a
bunch of frightening mythical creatures
along the way so you have to use a
variety of katanas great axes magic
scrolls and more just to survive neo
comes exclusively to ps4 on Tuesday
februari 7 and if you're not quite sure
about taking on the challenge head over
to gamespot for our review now let's
jump over to steam where there's a
cutesy 3d platformer you might have
missed last week poi takes its cues from
nintendo 64 classics like super mario 64
and banjo kazooie and it stars two young
kids who travel across levels full of
hills and snow fields and deserts to
become master explorers there are over
100 medallions to collect along the way
and you'll have to master all sorts of
tricky jumps and special tools to grab
them all the best part you don't have to
wait toys available on PC right now
let's stick with steam for the rest of
the week because there are a ton of
fresh indie games on the way leading the
charge is splasher this 2d platformer
arms you with a paint cannon and you'll
have to use the many colors of the
rainbow to make it through the ink Corp
factory watery blue ink works like a
jetpack red ink lets you stick to walls
and yellow ink lets you bounce off of
surfaces like a trampoline if you want
to rescue your fellow splashers from the
evil a duct or you can do it on PC on
the 7th
now we'll spend some time with induction
better yet let's rewind time because
that's what this abstract puzzle game is
all about it focuses on cause and effect
so you'll have to keep track of how
pushing switches moving blocks and
crossing bridges affects your little
moving cube induction may seem simple on
the surface but all those elements can
get totally borked if you alter
something in the past without thinking
it's colorful its angular and you can
start solving its 50-plus puzzles on PC
on the 7th speaking of going back in
time gunmetal Arcadia looks like a game
straight out of the NES era the sequel
to gunmetal Arcadia 0 combines that
retro style with platforming and a good
dose of action with over 75 weapons and
items you'll have to use a combination
of bombs swords scrolls and all sorts of
knickknacks as you help the tech elves
fight against the evil unmade Empire if
you're yearning for a roguelike game
that looks just like you're playing on
an old CRT TV set you can give gunmetal
arcadia look on pc on the 7th and those
are the biggest games will be playing
this week as always remember that
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change
thanks for watching guys I'll see you
next time
[Music]
you
[Music]